Have you heard about School Incorporated?
It’s a new PBS series that
looks at America’s schools and
schools around the world.
Makes interesting points about what’s
wrong with our schools
and what might be done about that.
The series though is long, it’s 3 hours, so
here’s my Stossel short attention span version.
Recognize this?
It’s the original Sony Walkman, introduced in 1979,
the first mainstream personal music player.
That was just the beginning.
Every year or two,
new and improved models hit the market.
To earn enough to buy the original Walkman,
you had to work two weeks
at a typical minimum wage job.
And that was for lo-fi sound
on cassettes you had to flip over every half an hour.
What’s really amazing about the rapid spread
and improvement of personal audio players
is that it isn’t amazing at all.
It’s perfectly normal.
A decade ago, no one had ever heard of Google.
Now they do tens of thousands
of internet searches per second.
Facebook went from
zero to half-a-billion members in just 5 years.
Basically, invent something good,
and it gets big.
And these days, it gets big fast.
But of all the products we make
and the services we provide,
there’s one that stands out
as an exception to that overall pattern;
one activity in which excellence doesn’t spawn
countless imitators or spread on a massive scale.
And that exception
is schooling.
For generations,
there hasn’t been a single innovation in teaching
that has transformed
classrooms and improved student achievement
worldwide.
Why not?
In America, the education establishment always says,
‘We need more money to makes schools better!'
But America's been trying that.
We tripled spending on government run schools
over the past 50 years,
and yet…
American test scores at the end of high school
have been flat since we started keeping track of them
all the way back in theearly 1970's.
Basically, educational quality has been stuck
in the era of disco and leisure suits
And while our top athletes and pop stars reach
huge audiences,
our greatest teachers seldom reach more than
a few dozen kids at a time.
Why not?
That’s the question at the heart of this series:
Coulson found some answers as to
why the best teachers don’t teach more kids
at California’s Garfield High.
By 1988,
more students were passing the advanced placement
calculus test here at Garfield
than at Beverly Hills High.
1 out of every 4 Mexican Americans who passed
AP calculus, nationwide,
attended Garfield.
Why?
Jaime Escalante
Time?
Three seconds
As a teacher, he was fantastic.
From the time he started teaching at Garfield in 1974,
Jaime Escalante worked as if his
life depended on the success of his students.
There was nothing but excellence
expected of us students.
We did not want to disappoint Jaime.
By 1982, the results were beyond belief
Literally!
His students performed so far above expectations
on the AP calculus test
that the Educational Testing Service
suspected cheating and threw out their scores.
Undaunted, they re-took it
and came through with flying colors a second time.
Hollywood noticed, dramatizing the story in
the movie Stand and Deliver.
This is basic math
but basic math is too easy for you, burros.
Seeing the movie makes me laugh,
it gives me a lot of memories as to
how it was in the classroom.
He taught me everything I needed
to be prepared for college.
In art as in life,
Escalante had a simple message for his students:
with enough drive and hard work,
the sky was the limit.
When his students went to college,
they found they were extra-well prepared.
Every one of those classes that I took
there was always a subject that I had already learned
in Mr. Jaime Escalante’s class in high school.
Louder!
A negative times a negative equals a positive.
Why?
The movie Stand and Deliver ends on a high note
with Escalante’s students proving the
skeptics wrong.
But the story of his mathematics program at Garfield
does not have a Hollywood ending.
Every single week
there was a new
film crew coming in.
In any other field,
we might expect this combination of success,
scalability, and publicity to
have catapulted Escalante to the top of his profession.
Or like Hubble’s expanding universe,
to have spread all across the country.
That just isn’t what happened.
A  lot of the teachers were resentful,
and it was very public.
The key
problem was that Escalante's classes were big.
He could handle it.
He was setting a precedent.
He was giving the message to the administrator:
“If Escalante can do it, why not you?”
So the teachers union marshaled enough votes
to oust Escalante as head of the math department.
Demoted and resented by many of his colleagues,
Escalante left Garfield High.
That’s the bad news.
The good news is that
there are places
where educational excellence is scaling up,
And so Coulson went to some of those places.
Sweden, Chile, London, India, Korea.
In Korea...
The top teachers earn more
than the highest paid professional baseball players.
My whole lecture revenue
is over
100 million dollars.
Really,
100 million dollars!
Coulson and I will explain how that happens
in the next video.